special relativity has undoubtedly been
one of the most successful theories to
emerge out of recent history
not only has the theory correctly
predicted new phenomena
but also in complementing more
sophisticated theories like general
relativity or Quantum field Theory it
has helped enhance our understanding of
both the very large and the very small
but despite all this it can be an
intuitively jarring Theory
and Einstein himself was in fact never
fully satisfied with it writing in 1914
that the theory suffered from what he
termed an undeniable fundamental defect
but what was this defect exactly
and how did he propose to overcome it
this is dialect
and today we're examining why relativity
doesn't add up
[Music]
every scientific theory is predicated
upon certain unprovable statements known
as axioms the axioms of classical
mechanics essentially Newton's three
laws more or less reflect intuitive
beliefs about our everyday reality
I.E that motion is related to causality
and force to motion
and action to reaction
Etc
but unlike those axioms the central
Axiom of special relativity that light
travels at the same speed in all
inertial frames is something of a head
scratcher
it tells us that no matter what velocity
observers are traveling at with respect
to one another they will all measure the
same speed for any given beam of light
unlike Newton's Laws this Axiom hardly
seems to follow as a consequence of any
intuitive ideas
yet by adopting it Einstein was able to
achieve quite a lot
unite electricity and magnetism under
one framework
show mass and energy were of the same
form
and dispense with the need for an
unobservable ether
but possibly the greatest Allure this
Axiom held for Einstein was that it
promised to overturn the absolute space
and time of Newtonian physics
Einstein was an avid devotee of Ernst
mock the philosopher who had stressed
that all laws in physics ought to
concern the relative motion of bodies
and not their motion as referred to some
theoretical absolutist construct
indeed by asserting the constancy of the
speed of light Einstein felt he was
achieving Mock's vision of a relative
space and time
but there was one thing he knew his new
Theory didn't yet relative eyes
motion
this was because it relied on an
implicit definition of observers being
inertial meaning unaccelerated
in order for them to measure a constant
speed of light
this quality of being unaccelerated was
not relative to individual observers but
rather somehow an objective fact already
agreed upon between all observers
meaning it was absolute
but Einstein recognized right away that
this absoluteness meant the existence of
an internal tension within his theory if
motion was defined through space and
time and space and time were relative
then how could motion be anything but
relative
indeed Einstein's immediate intuition
told him this meant the theory of
special relativity was incomplete
sure he had framed the laws of physics
to be independent of any particular
velocity
but this had already been a feature of
Newtonian mechanics into Conformity with
Which special relativity merely brought
the laws of electromagnetism
to Einstein true relativity meant the
relativity of all motion not just the
relativity of velocities
for that reason in a 1914 paper entitled
on the relativity problem he wrote that
he felt special relativity suffered from
the same undeniable fundamental defect
that Newtonian physics did that is that
it relied on a notion of absolute
acceleration in order to complete its
formalism
so why do we care whether a formalism
invokes absolute acceleration or not
well as Einstein pointed out in his
paper it's because absolute acceleration
is undefinable
one would try in vain to explain what it
is that one should understand by the
pure and simple acceleration of a body
one would succeed only in defining the
relative acceleration of bodies with
respect to each other
indeed to make a statement about any
sort of motion meaningful be it velocity
acceleration jerk Etc you have to
specify what you're moving relative to
for instance if you say you're
accelerating in a car you're implying
that you're accelerating relative to the
ground
but if that ground were say actually the
deck of a boat accelerating equally and
oppositely over a body of water
then relative to someone on the shore
you'd actually be at rest
no physicist in their right mind would
of course admit that you could have
acceleration which is not relative to
anything
and So formalistically speaking the
answer to this problem is to define
absolute acceleration as meaning
acceleration relative to an inertial
frame
but of course inertial frames are
defined via an absence of acceleration
so this definition is horrifically
circular
indeed most physicists will esue giving
that definition altogether in favor of
the empirical one where an absolute
acceleration is defined as something
that can be measured with an
accelerometer
unfortunately since any measuring
instrument first has to be calibrated
before it can give meaningful readings
this answer is likewise problematic
for instance given a spring
accelerometer we'd have to make a choice
of where and when to calibrate it before
we could use it
and should we choose to calibrate it on
a rocket ship that unbeknownst to us was
blasting through outer space
then as soon as the rocket engines shut
off the spring would stretch leading us
to wrongly conclude that we had begun
experiencing a force
attempts to utilize a better or more
sophisticated accelerometer will not
bypass this calibration requirement
meaning acceleration as measured by an
accelerometer is always only
acceleration relative to the frame of
calibration
there is yet still one intuitive
definition of absolute motion left to us
which you can find given in videos such
as this Ted Edwin on the twin paradox
this is the idea that absolute
acceleration I.E non-inertial motion can
be defined as acceleration with respect
to the rest of the universe
to be in a national Observer one has to
maintain a constant speed and direction
relative to the rest of the universe
well on the surface this definition is
highly appealing It suffers from a
crucial defect it's non-local
that is if acceleration is supposed to
be a real effect then the information
that something is accelerating must be
transmitted to that something at the
moment that the acceleration occurs
but if information can only travel at
the speed of light then this information
can't come from a great distance away
in other words you can only be causally
affected by things in your immediate
vicinity so the state of motion of the
rest of the universe relative to you at
the moment of your acceleration is both
irrelevant and impossible to know
whatever you're accelerating relative to
it must be located within your immediate
vicinity and infinitesimally so should
we take this notion of local action to
its limit
this means that if we want to treat
acceleration as absolutely and
instantaneously real then we are left
with only two options for what you are
accelerating relative to
1. an absolute space
or two
some ether-like substance
a special relativity of course rejects
both these possibilities telling us that
we can have neither absolutes nor ethers
but Einstein developed special
relativity in 1905 before he ventured
into any considerations about how
acceleration played into the picture
so it's natural to see why he and others
might have leapt to the conclusion that
absolute space and or an ether could be
dismissed altogether
however by the time 1914 rolled around
Einstein had well past realized that the
notion of absolute acceleration didn't
mesh with his relativistic Paradigm and
so to correct this undeniable
fundamental defect he concluded in his
1914 paper that the laws of physics
ought to be packaged in a way so as to
refer to only the motion between bodies
indeed in 1914 Einstein felt extremely
confident that his pending theory of
general relativity would achieve exactly
that
this was because Einstein had begun
working with tensors
a type of mathematical object which
seemed to provide a way to relate the
laws of physics without reference to any
particular coordinate system
eager for a way to realize Mock's
program of unfettered relativism
Einstein mistakenly conflated this
coronet-free aspect of tensors with the
relativity of all motion and concluded
he had finally done away with the Last
Vestige of Newtonian absolutism
but Einstein received a serious blow in
1917 when the German physicist Eric
crutchman pointed out to him that
tensors were simply a convenient way of
mathematically packaging a formalism and
that pretty much any old Theory could be
expressed through them
sure enough only a few years later the
French mathematician Elite managed to
reformulate classical Newtonian physics
in the language of cornet-free tensors
developing what became known as Newton
kirtan physics
the implication of this was clear if the
absolute space time and motion of
Newtonian physics could be expressed in
the language of tensors then the tensor
formalism of general relativity
indicated nothing whatsoever in regards
to motion being absolute or relative
for the remainder of his life Einstein
would struggle to interpret the meaning
of Relativity changing his mind
frequently about its implications and
completely reversing his stances on
topics such as the existence of The
Ether
or Mock's principle
but mainstream physics would ignore all
this and merely retain the philosophy of
Relativity as Einstein had established
it in 1905 before he had given full
weight to the meaning of acceleration
which means Einstein never succeeded in
removing his Theory's fundamental defect
and that this defect Still Remains with
the theory today
indeed it's easy to see that this defect
comes about because we want to treat
acceleration as absolutely real and yet
at the same time persist in saying that
all the components which go into making
up acceleration time space length
velocity are all relative
foreign
's instinct to solve this problem by
relativizing acceleration was certainly
correct
but as we mentioned before if we want
all observers to agree on their states
of acceleration whilst also preserving
the principle of local action this
leaves only two options for what
observers can be accelerating relative
to an absolute space
or an ether
since the whole point of Relativity is
to avoid problematical absolutes this
means we must cross the first option off
our list which leaves only the second
option The Ether
and thus at once we see why relativity
is internally inconsistent
in order to handle acceleration the
formalism requires the existence of an
ether
but at the same time its philosophy
conceived only for constant velocity
motion forbids us to speak of any such
ether
of course it's hardly a coincidence that
Einstein would eventually change his
mind and declare that The Ether did
exist
nor is it a coincidence that it would be
considerations of gravity and
acceleration which would lead him to do
so
because for all the mystery surrounding
what The Ether may or may not be what
our current theories most strongly
suggest is the idea that we detect its
presence every time we accelerate
of course you might object that if we
can have a measurable acceleration with
respect to the ether then we must also
have a measurable velocity with respect
to the ether
which brings us back round to the
central mystery of relativity
if the ether exists why can't we detect
our velocity with respect to it
the lorenzian answer to this question
was to modify Newtonian physics with an
additional Axiom
stating that clocks physically slow down
and rulers physically shrink when in
motion with respect to the ether
this Axiom in and of itself feels pretty
arbitrary and jarring
but at the same time the Axiom Einstein
replaced it with that the speed of light
is measurably equal in all inertial
frames hardly feels any less arbitrary
or jarring
neither are intuitive and both leave one
essentially scratching their head going
why that
but what if we could find another Axiom
a deeper more intuitive principle from
which these two seemingly conflicting
axioms would actually emerge as being
one in the same thing
indeed some of you who have been
following this channel for a while have
been very patient with us as for some
time now we've been dotting our eyes and
crossing our T's in order to bring you
an interpretation of Relativity which we
feel will offer a more intuitive and
concrete way of understanding the
Theory's formalism
our aim is to strip the theory of its
mathematical abstraction and demonstrate
that to every counter-intuitive and
bizarre phenomenon a simple and
physically meaningful picture can be
coordinated
now of course none of this would have
been possible without the encouragement
insights and guidance from our viewers
over the years
additionally we want to express our
gratitude for our patreon supporters
without whose generosity this Channel's
continuance would also not be possible
and lastly we want to acknowledge Henry
Lindner whose paper on the philosophical
inadequacy of modern physics served as
the inspiration for this video
[Music]
well until soon this has been dialect
thanks for watching